ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola lespo qué tal me traigo me están
las ciertas con chile abiertas con
chocolate de manzana y chile tiene una
cobertura de tamarindo que no se pega ni
las minas y 230 y de chile en pública
que aouate japonés y un botecito de
chame me llama incluye está marín dicha
muy preparado o la de chocolate tiene
encaje de chocolate viaje hace colores y
bombones cuentas donde creencias
y las tranquilas no se empiecen a parar
que hoy no les vengo a vender aunque tal
vez para sacar algunos pedidos pero
bueno hoy les vengo hoy les vengo a
compartir compartir un poco de cómo
inició esta aventura emprendedora este
interno emprendedor dando inicio así
toda linda y con un espacio para
aprendido nada que ver mi mente el
emprendedor inicia hace cinco años y no
inició con manzanas inició con fruta se
llamaba fruta lo que ha de quedar le
llama era muy buena pero en la red en la
realidad no fácil compré unos moldes de
flores de corazones y mucha fruta
pepinos y gemas jícama manzana y sandía
y como era una chiquitín mi mamá no me
dejaba utilizar el cuchillo a mi mamá le
tocó cortar toda la fruta no sé cuántos
tengan niños pero espero que se puedan
imaginar aquello fue la locura puntocom
tengo dos hermanitos pequeños que me
querían ayudar uno quería probar cada
pedazo disfrutan y el otro pensó que la
frutera confeti la casa el día quedó
cómo explicarlo quedó peor que donde se
perdió la guerra de los pasteles por esa
razón fue debut y despedida de aquel
emprendimiento
mi mamá me dijo busca otra idea y como
yo había leído que sea emprendedor no
era nada fácil que por ello los expertos
recomiendan emprender en algo que te
guste pues decidí buscar en internet más
ideas pero yo quería seguir con algo
relacionado al tema y esa misma noche me
encontré con manzanas cubiertas manzanas
fruta me encanta y no era necesario
utilizar cuchillo en el negocio perfecto
para una niña de 7 años y por supuesto
que no quise perder el tiempo y así
inició mi negocio al día siguiente estos
botes de mi primer día con mi negocio
sacando pedidos y entregando los pedidos
así que muchos son de estar pensando
también talla con este carisma juega con
ventaja frente a otros emprendedores
todos le han de comprar todos le han
decir que sí
les aclaro no es así y para contarles
esta aventura emprendedora la divide en
tres etapas la primera es vivir en
contra
esta etapa sentí como que dios y la vida
me estaban probando ya que cada vez que
saca sacado pedidos entregárnoslo vía
si yo de no me importa si dejaba pasar
una semana o tres meses el día que yo
hacía manzana sólo se entregaba llovía
en esta etapa también me di cuenta del
gran equipo que tengo por supuesto mi
papá era el banco ya que cada vez que me
gastaba todo el dinero que ganaba le
tocaba prestarme nuevamente mis
hermanitos según ellos eran entonces ya
que me ayudan pero comerse el material y
mi mamá me cuidaba mientras yo sacaba y
entregaba pedidos sí espero que todos
puedan entender lo que es tener una
familia normal aunque ya abrí la
película y no es así entonces esta etapa
siguió así y en esta etapa pues hubo
muchas críticas pero personas cercanas y
así pero las tuvimos que superar
y sigo así y me entrevistaron en
televisión esta es la primera
experiencia y fue super ya que desde
en esta entrevista hubo personas que la
vieron y se quedaron o sea su perfil
siempre se llenaron y me felicitaron y
otras que no si hay envidia en el mundo
y hay
ya cada tiene un final
y así siguieron las entrevistas entre
fui a dar una conferencia conocí gracias
a mi negocio al presidente municipal de
tijuana que me invitaron a una
conferencia lamentablemente no puedo
estar ahí por cuestiones del municipio
todos están de acuerdo porque este día
no estuviera
y pues fue super ya que a esta edad a
los 8 años en la escuela no paraban de
decirme que guardara el silencio y aquel
día tenía un gran grupo de personas solo
para escucharme a mí si saben lo que es
para una niña que la escuela no le digan
le digan que guarde silencio y que un
día haya personas queriendo escuchar fue
súper esa experiencia después me
invitaron a una sesión de fotos con una
televisión en una revista local y me
invitaron a una sesión de fotos con
otros niños sí ahí está yo en esa sesión
de fotos me sentí como un modelo hasta
les daba instrucciones a los fotógrafos
y era la primera
después me invitaron al tecmilenio a dar
una conferencia en la semana de la
felicidad donde conocí a la voz de todos
mis personajes favoritos y los alumnos
me pidieron autógrafos eso no es
sentirse toda una conferencista de
sentirse una rockstar sí espero que
algunos ya hayan pasado por aquella
experiencia
pasando el tiempo me entrevistar bueno
unos meses después me entrevistaron en
un periódico local anteriormente en la
revista que me entrevistaron me enojé un
poquito porque no sale en portada sí
bueno no fácil y super mente de esas que
hacemos los niños cuando no conseguimos
lo que queremos pero por supuesto
agradecí soy una niña normal hacemos
berrinches como todos los demás duermo y
me se me sale la baba pero si vela
limpio bueno
agradecí pero me puse de meta echarle
más ganas para que la siguiente en la
siguiente entrevista sí salieron portada
y no fue casi un año después que me
invitaron a un periódico local y si fue
para las portadas fue súper ya que mi
entrevista fue acompañada por una
psicóloga que dice que tenemos que los
padres tienen que apoyar a los hijos
para que sean grandes emprendedores o lo
que ellos quieran como los futbolistas
los ingenieros sí y así fue pasando el
tiempo
y
no sé si algunos ya me conocen
tengo dos hermanitos pequeños en aquella
en aquella exposición pues ellos dijeron
y porque a mí no me dieron aceite si yo
ahí traigo el gafete de expositor
entonces tuvimos que ir a conseguir dos
galletas para mis hermanitos que ellos
llevaban brochetas sí y algo en facebook
está el vídeo ellos expusieron sin
después de me dijeron y porque nosotros
no podemos hacer eso es así que siente
increíble poder ser la inspiración de
tus hermanos después de todo esto hubo
una entrevista se abrieron más puertas
más a más conferencias ya más
entrevistas pero hay una de las cual les
quiero contar en esta conferencia fue
invitada por una psicóloga madre de
familia que pensó que yo podría inspirar
a mi generación así fui a una secundaria
pública en la que los niños pensaban que
no tenían nada poder por delante si yo
fue a poner mi granito de arena y fui a
inspirarlos a decirles que no importa tu
nivel económico
y quiénes son tus padres y menos donde
naciste la vida siempre te da opciones
siempre está oportunidades siempre se
puede salir adelante y es por ello que
me pareció interesante e importante
compartirles esta aventura emprendedora
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]